hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ihr wisst ja dass ich nach meinem
Abitur mit 18 Jahren direkt nach Köln
gezogen bin hier studiert habe und auch
jetzt mittlerweile noch immer an meiner
Wohnung hier in Köln lebe so oder so
wird es auch für mich langsam an der
Zeit allerdings ein Haus zu bauen und
daher habe ich mir gedacht gibt es
keinen besseren Simulator dafür als den
Bau Simulator den wir heute spielen
werden zunächst einmal müssen wir hier
ein Profil erstellen guck mal die sieht
doch eins zu eins aus wie wir lila name
äh äh aber jetzt müssen wir auch noch
eine Firma erstellen ich verdiene ganz
alleine als Youtuber 20 Millionen im
Jahr wofür brauche ich eine Firma
als Logo würde ich sagen nehmen wir
einfach mal diesen Hammer weil wir auch
der Hammer sind und als Firmenname
nehmen wir auch der Hammer Barbara
Bauhaus unterwegs meine Damen und Herren
ein krasses Unwetter wütet in unserer
Stadt
die irgendwie nur aus einer Straße
besteht wir sind schon sexy wir müssen
glaube ich hier vorne zu dem Punkt hin
der noch ein paar Meter entfernt ist
denn wir sollen mit Hape reden
sieht auch sehr chillig aus wie die
Straßen gebaut wurden es sieht aber auf
jeden Fall sehr cute hier aus also hier
vorne war die Hauptstraße hier vorne
können wir runterlaufen ich sprinte man
ein bisschen dann geht's glaube ich
einen Ticken schneller hier vorne lang
und hier ist Hape ein langjähriger
Kollege von uns als dann die grauen
Zellen noch am Auftauen sind ich bin's
aber ich kenne dich ich habe schon immer
gedacht dass du eine große Zukunft in
der Baubranche vor dir haben würdest
dachte ich mir auch jetzt wäre die
Gelegenheit dich zu beweisen denn ich
brauche dringend deine Hilfe ist
komplett egal wir überspringen den
ganzen Scheiß ich weiß nicht was ich
machen muss wir fahren hier vorne 8,500
Meter Entfernung können
[Musik]
Entschuldigung
ich weiß nicht was das für eine Ampel
ist aber warum kann ich sowas umfahren
wenn ich allerdings gegen eine Ampel
fahre passiert sowas hier vorne sind wir
jetzt allerdings schon bei der Baustelle
angekommen sieht irgendwie genauso aus
wie da wo wir haben gerade getroffen
haben aber gut ich steig mal aus und wir
waren deine Nachricht habe zuerst
brauchen wir Licht schalte die mobilen
Generator ein
wie kann Hape schneller hier sein als
ich das jetzt anscheinend der mobile
Generator den schalten wir jetzt einfach
mal kurz ein
ah chillig so genau so schalte ich auch
Mann Generator ein und jetzt müssen wir
den Erdhaufen von der fahrbahnräumen
deswegen ab in den
die denk ich die brauchen wir alles
erklären ne ich habe 30 Jahre lang Bau
Bau bauen
Alter wer braucht den Steuerung hier
vorne geht's Polizei
wie mache ich denn jetzt hier die Erde
weg
das hört sich irgendwie nicht so ganz
gesund ansehen sie können den später
ich hänge fest
meine Reifen drehen durch
ich wollte doch einfach nur mein
Traumhaus bauen
[Musik]
guck mal
alles abgetragen unten steht Stelle den
Radlader den markierten Bereich und gehe
zu Hape aber das werden wir nicht tun
denn Hape hat es verdient weil er so
schnell hingefahren und uns nicht
mitgenommen hat dass der Rest vom Sand
komplett
[Musik]
ja oder halt dahinter
kann ich ihn umfahren
geht auch nicht
ich hänge fest jetzt ist die Fahrbahn
wieder halbseitig freigegeben
danke allerdings endet unser Einsatz
hier noch nicht was beim örtlichen
Supermarkt ist die Kühlung ausgefallen
auf der Ladefläche von Pritschenwagen
steht ein mobiler Generator
Pritschenwagen das Teil so schnell wie
möglich zum Supermarkt schaffen damit
die Kühlung wieder läuft und die
Lebensmittel nicht verderben der mobile
Generator steht auf unserem LKW oben
drauf dementsprechend steigen wir ein
und fahren zu unserem Ziel habe
so wie ich den kenne der bleibt da
stehen ist trotzdem Erde als wir jetzt
als ich mich auch mal alle Verkehrsregel
wir sind angekommen beim Supermarkt hier
vorne und können direkt zur Tankstelle
wir müssen direkt hier vorne reinfahren
Funktionsmodus Modus wechseln und er
ich sag's kein drittes Mal ich habe
Baumarkt Arbeiten studiert lass mich in
Ruhe mit eurer Steuerung
okay das war das Licht an und aus ach
guck mal so sitzen drin
[Musik]
aber gut fahren wir den Generator ein
Stückchen nach unten
aber gut Freunde bei der Firma der
Hammer wird natürlich
der Kunde groß geschrieben so abhaken
haben wir erledigt Generator muss
eingeschaltet werden kriege ich doch
auch easien sag hingehen geh Generator
einschalten und
der Supermarkt läuft wieder
kann ich jetzt mein Traumhaus bauen die
Laterne hat das Dach eingerissen und
muss dabei einige Leitungen beschädigt
haben habe ich gesehen da muss eine neue
Verkleidung drauf macht der Kollege
zunächst die Laterne aus dem Dach und
fahre dann zum örtlichen Baustoffhandel
um die benötigten Teile abzuholen wir
sollten keine Zeit verlieren
ich habe ein Recht auf Pause nicht
vertragen Barbara Bau Fragen ich habe so
die ganze Zeit schon gesagt so also das
Team jetzt erstmal runter ach du oh mein
Gott nein rechts nein links links links
links zurück nach links nein weiter nach
rechts Alter ich kann kotzen
ja wie auf dem Jahrmarkt hier
runter damit
und jetzt abhaken haben wir
Barbara bau mal wieder ihren Job
erledigt wir fahren allerdings jetzt zum
nächsten Baustelle der Supermarkt hat
unsere Arbeit bekommen
[Applaus]
Barbara Bau ist da und jetzt sind wir
hier am Baumarkt angekommen namens
hammergeil
der einfach unseren Namen geklaut wir
steigen jetzt auf jeden Fall hier in den
Gabel
komplett aus
wir beladen jetzt unseren Gabelstapler
[Musik]
er hängt fest
der Gabelstapler hängt auch fest
es geht dir keine Richtung vor geht
nicht zurück geht nicht okay okay
jetzt hänge ich jetzt welche wir
probieren es jetzt mal aus der
Perspektive hier und fahren auch erstmal
einen kleinen Bogen so dass wir oh mein
Gott wie kann das noch klauen ne
wie geil ist das denn oh nein wir fahren
jetzt ganz ganz vorsichtig an unsere
zweite Kiste hier ran das Ding ist schon
ganz unten warte mal vielleicht von der
Seite nee auch nicht noch weiter runter
weiter runter geht's nicht perfekt wir
schauen mal von an Perspektive wieso
kann ich das nicht einladen
[Musik]
man musste einfach nur noch mehr Anlauf
nehmen aber gut wir haben die Ladung auf
jeden Fall geladen und daher schieben
wir den ganzen Bums jetzt auch mal ein
Stückchen nach oben fahren zu unserem
LKW und laden das jetzt hier ab indem
wir erstmal natürlich ein bisschen
weiter runterfahren und
[Musik]
das hört sich nicht so gesund an danach
habe ich fünf Minuten lang probiert eine
andere Lösung zu finden indem ich den
Kran meines LKWs benutze um die Ladung
auf den LKW zu laden doch dann nee oder
das ist jetzt nicht wahr
weiter klappt das nicht
weiter geht's nicht
weiter geht's nicht ich komme nicht an
die
[Musik]
das ist das beschissenste Spiel was ich
je gespielt habe
ich wollte meinen Traumhaus
stattdessen spiele ich hier so ein
Scheiß wo ich Erde verladen muss ich
kann wirklich kotz